So I quickly want to sort of introduce
how virtualization actually helps us
in limiting the damage that can
be caused by a compromised or
hacked operating system.
Okay, we said, maybe you want to run
more than one operating system on
the same underlying hardware but this is
going to help us with security as well.
So, limiting the damage of
a hacked operating system.
Let's see, how can we do that
when we have virtualization?
Okay, the way we do that is we change
the picture where we had the hardware
and the operating system,
well we introduce something between
the hardware and the operating system.
And that is called a Hypervisor.
On top of the Hypervisor, we support
what is called virtual machines.
And these virtual machines have
their own operating system.
It's called the guest operating system.
And the guest operating
system then can support
a number of applications that
run within that virtual machine.
So if you, we look at our earlier
picture, we have the hardware,
then we have the Hypervisor,
then we have this virtual machines.
So this is the OS here and
the application here.
Compromise of an OS here only
affects these applications in
this virtual machine.
It doesn't do anything to
the application that may be running
in this different virtual machine.
With the same operating system or
a different operating system.
What we really have is isolation
between virtual machines.
So earlier,
we had isolation between processes or
applications, and they all shared
the same operating system.
Now we have isolation between
different virtual machines.
Each has it's own operating system or
guest operating system.
So I can do my package in
one virtual machine while
browsing potentially dangerous places on
the web in a different virtual machine.
Anything bad that happens in the second
virtual machine, or VM2, should not
affect your tax stuff that you're
doing in your first virtual machine.
So the tested computed base
really here is the Hypervisor.
In the picture that we had before
where we had the hardware and
the trusted computing base and
then the application.
It changes with virtualization
where we have the hardware,
Hypervisor, and
then the virtual machines and
those virtual machines have
their own operating system.